In the last video
we saw that if we
had a market with
perfect competition,
and if the current
short-term equilibrium
price is above the
price the necessary
or is above the price at which
firms would be generating
economic profit, then
more and more firms
would start entering.
Because if the economic
profit is positive,
then that means
it's a better place
to use your resources than
whatever your opportunity
cost is, that
you're making profit
above and beyond your
opportunity cost.
So more and more
people enter it.
So after a little bit,
after one company enters it,
or maybe the same firms
starts adding more seat miles
or adding more planes, than we
have another short-term supply
curve that looks like that.
And then there's a
new equilibrium price
that's a little bit lower,
and a new equilibrium quantity
that's a little bit higher.
And that keeps happening.
Still your equilibrium price
was higher than your price
necessary for a normal profit,
or a zero economic profit.
And so more people enter still.
And so we have another
short-term supply curve.
And we move further
to the bottom right
of this demand curve.
And it keeps happening until
we have a supply curve, where
the equilibrium price, where
this new short-term equilibrium
price, is the same as the price
at which everyone is making
a normal profit, or the
price needed for zero
economic profit.
At that point,
people are neutral
whether they drop out or
enter into the market,
and so the quantity
remains stable.
And so that's why we view
each of these curves over here
as our short-run supply curves.
But this line right over here--
let me do this in a new color,
let me do it in yellow,
this line over here,
we've talked about this
in previous videos--
that's why this line over here
we call our long-run supply
curve.
Because depending on whether
the equilibrium price is
above or below
this, at some point,
supply will enter
or exit the system
so that we eventually
get back to some point
along this long-run supply
curve right over here.
Now, this was assuming
perfect competition.
Many players,
identical products,
we did it for air travel,
no barriers to entry.
Let's think about
what happens if we
have the exact opposite
of perfect competition.
So we're going to start
at the same point.
We're going to start there.
So we're going to start
at the green supply curve.
And we have this
orange demand curve.
But let's say that instead of
having perfect competition,
we live in a country
where-- and there
are countries like
this-- where they
say there's only one air
carrier that can do business.
It is the national air
carrier in our country.
And so instead of many players,
we now have one player.
And then obviously,
it's identical product.
Well, they only have
one product, one player.
Huge barriers to entry.
No one else.
You could also say
infinite barriers to entry.
No one else by law is
allowed to enter into this.
So I'm going to
the extreme case.
And obviously, there is
the ultimate advantage
for the existing player.
They are the one
that the government
is allowing to participate.
And price information, we
don't really care about.
There's only one price quote
coming from one player.
Now when we do that,
when we talk about one
player as the only
player in the market,
we are not talking about
perfect competition.
We are then talking
about a monopoly.
And it is the same
word as perhaps one
of your favorite board games.
And the point of
that board game is
to own all of the properties
of one of those colors.
So at least in the framework
of that board game,
of the Monopoly board game,
the Parker Brothers board game,
you have a monopoly on the blue.
If you own Park
Place and Boardwalk,
you have a monopoly on
that part of the market.
So then that's
what you try to do.
When you have a monopoly, you
can then charge higher prices
for when someone
lands on your space.
And something very
similar will happen here.
Now, we only have one player.
And let's say right now the
equilibrium price is higher
than the price you need to
have zero economic profit.
So you have one player, and
that player is definitely
getting some serious
economic profit.
Well, they can just sit there,
because no one else can enter.
You're not going to
have this trend where
more and more supply
gets on the market
until you get to this
long-run supply curve.
In fact, there will not be
this long-run supply curve.
The long-run supply curve
is whatever, frankly,
the monopolist decides
they want to do.
If this is where their
profits are optimized,
they'll do there.
In fact, they can even
go the other direction.
Even though they're already
making some economic profit,
they might determine,
hey, we can make even more
economic profit if we lower
the quantity offered even more.
So they might even take
supply out of the market.
And so they could
have a new supply
curve that looks like this.
And we have a new equilibrium
price that is even higher.
And it's at a lower
equilibrium quantity.
They could even do it more.
They could even raise
price even more.
And so then you have a
new equilibrium price
that is up here, and a
lower equilibrium quantity.
So clearly, when you have a
monopoly, something not so good
is happening for the consumer.
They're able to raise price.
It's actually not
even efficient,
because the optimal quantity
is not being produced.
But I want to leave
you there and maybe
leave you with something
to think about.
I said that the monopolists
now, because they
don't have to worry about
other people entering in
to lower the price and get
to this normal profit line,
because they don't have
to worry about that,
they can set their quantity
to whatever they want.
Or I guess another way
you can think about it,
they can set their prices to
whatever they want and get
the corresponding quantity.
But the question is,
how do they set that?
How would they determine
where along this curve
that they would like to
either set the price,
or I guess you could say set the
quantity by limiting production
in some way?